jordan lyles on the mound lyle's
right-handed pitcher is making his
fourth appearance and his third start
out of hartsville south carolina jp
crawford is inside the batter's box
lyles delivers and that pitch is
rocketed to center solak freezes comes
in now backs up reaches up and he makes
the catch here's first baseman dylan
moore and it's lone outside for ball
force so moore with a one-out walk here
in the top of the first inning it's
center fielder kyle lewis having an
outstanding start to the season and he
swings to the first pitch and lifts it
high in the air to the right field
corner gallow gets to the track now
comes in and he makes the catch so moore
goes back to first that brings up kyle
seeger pitch from lyles fastball runner
goes the sliding head first into second
base and safe is dylan moore with steal
number four the throw by catcher jeff
mathis was late so dylan on its second
base with two outs and sega rips one of
first speared by ref tonight reaching
towards the line ending the inning here
in the top of the first rangers coming
up to face veteran right-hander taiwan
walker with a 5.79 era getting ready for
his fourth start of the season shinsu to
lead things off basketball swinging a
ground ball into the ship diving try way
to his left is crawford can't get off
the throw jp crawford went diving to his
left onto the outfield grass and he
tried to shot put the throw and the ball
just kind of fell out of his hand as he
went down to the turret so chew with a
base hit to lead things off here in the
bottom of the first inning that'll bring
up third baseman isaiah connor philippa
here's the next pitch wong on ground
ball right side up with the ball is long
backhand toss jp at second got it throws
the first end time double play two outs
so here's willie walker not wasting any
time below the pace breaking ball
swinging a chopper to the right side
charging the shortstop crawford with a
shift on got it underhand tossed to
moore at first in time to get calhoun
and that will end the inning nice start
for taiwan walker here in the bottom of
the first catcher austin nola leading
off the top half of the second swung on
and a fly ball deep into left center
field solac going back to the warning
track near the wall goodbye baseball
austin nola and he puts the mariners on
top by a score of one to nothing so long
with the walker that's the second walk
given up by jordan lyles brings up
designated hitter daniel vogelback
nowhere to go but up for daniel
vogelback hitting it 103. bogey gets
into one this might be the one to get
him out of the slop say goodbye
a two-run bomb by vogelback and the
mariners have a three-nothing lead
that's a starter right there so that's
gonna load him up with just one out and
kyle lewis coming up swung on and a fly
ball into right center field going back
to his left so lacking gallow to his
right it's going to be gallo who makes
the catch tagging at third is lopes
heading home he will score and the
mariners have four nothing lead so two
on two outs four runs are in and here's
third baseman kyle seeger and that one's
lifted in the air to the left center so
lacks got to play on it coming in and
towards the alley
underneath that he makes the catch and
that ends it rangers have none of the
corners in two outs and a chance to cut
into this four-run deficit here's willy
calhoun swinging a ground ball hopping
right to jp crawford shortstop flung
over the shift makes the throw onto
first base for round number three
runners stranded on the corners and
walker escapes trouble though the
rangers have two in scoring position
trailing four nothing in the bottom of
the fourth for elvis time one in some
trouble and the 2-2 to andrew slider
swing and a miss for strike three so he
got the strikeout with a slider
strikeout number three for taiwan walker
in his biggest strikeout
in this ball game and the banner will be
first baseman rob ref style check swing
does he go yes he does strike three big
strikeout for taiwan walker and that
will end the inning so two on and two
away for left fielder tim lopes there's
a drive to center solac moving to his
left
he cruises underneath that and makes the
catch and that ends the inning rangers
with another man in scoring position
another opportunity for elvis they've
left six on and it might be seven as
elvis grounds went ashore crawford's
there but the throws low and it gets by
the first baseman moore dietrich around
third he comes home and he scores and
what should have been a routine ground
out to end the inning ends up as an e6
that helps the rangers get on the board
here's red snyder swinging a ground ball
jp crawford dives smothers flips it out
of his glove on to shedlong and it ends
the inning tremendous play by jp
crawford and it gets taiwan walker out
of six brilliant innings tonight in
arlington two tags from second he heads
to third and willie calhoun coming up
flair out towards right field tough spot
and it does drop in two comes home to
score and the rangers are now down four
to two and yes indeed joey gallo come to
the plate as the tying run swing and a
miss for strike three perfectly placed
lower outside corner gatto comes up
empty and that is the seventh inning
here we go the bases are loaded one out
bottom of the eighth inning the
batteries catcher jeff mathis and mathis
swings and hits this one in the air that
might be a tough spot nobody home and it
drops in base hit it gets a run to the
plate and it's a 4-3 ball game and two
at the plate and he hits this one high
in the air
right field will it be deep enough
andrew's tank smith
makes the catch andrew's headed to the
plate here comes the throw he comes
through andrew scores and we're tied at
four the bases are loaded for willie
calhoun it's way inside and it gets away
here comes frasier and the rangers are
on top five to four two one kowloon
swings and shoots one through the left
side of they sit and the rangers have
increased the lead on a two-run single
for willy calhoun they now lead 7-4
raphael montero is on in the ninth and
the mariners are down to their final out
got him swaying and montero locks it
down in the ninth inning that's a 7-4
rangers win